welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters the jury reached a verdict
that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum read the
jury find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage gross croix we the jury find the
defendant kyle adrian kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
kyle rittenhouse brought to tears as the
jury held his fate in their hands and
their verdict was read
not guilty on all charges justice was
served our system works this was a
clear-cut case of self-defense the jury
was under intense pressure by protesters
and the media to deliver a guilty
verdict the jurors were being
photographed followed and stalked by
activists and the press
but they were able to see past the
corruption and intimidation the
prosecutors were rogue and reckless they
rushed the charges and then overcharged
just to feed the mob the body it wanted
but the jury bucked the mob they
listened to the testimony watched the
videos from that night and heard
directly from the defendant himself
here's what the defense had to say after
the verdict
you know i wish nobody died i wish i
never met kyle rittenhouse and i don't
mean that because he was a bad client i
just mean
because then this wouldn't have happened
you know
justice is done when the truth is
reached and i don't know that it's set
up to do that but a prosecutor is
supposed to seek the truth it's not
about winning and this case became about
winning
the media lies triggered the riot which
ended up costing millions in damage and
two lives
remember this is the same media who
wants you to believe there were mostly
peaceful protests going on as the fire
was blazing behind them
did they stop no
the press polluted the jury pool
slandered the defendant and attacked the
judge
make no mistake this verdict represented
a massive loss for the corporate media
their power is slowly slipping away the
racial vigilante storylines
they sold all of those folded
and did they learn their lesson
after the verdict politicians fanned the
race flames corey bush tweeting this
quote the judge the jury the defendant
it's white supremacy in action the
system isn't built to hold white
supremacists accountable it's why black
and brown folks are brutalized and put
in cages while white supremacist
murderers walk free this case has
nothing to do with race it was for white
men
the media will have to answer for what
they did
like this headline from msnbc kyle
rittenhouse trial was designed to
protect white conservatives who kill
seems fair
even the disgraced athlete colin
kaepernick jumped on the bandwagon
tweeting we just witnessed a system
built on white supremacy validate the
terroristic acts of a white supremacist
this only further validates the need to
abolish our current system white
supremacy cannot be reformed
the media and those who ignore the truth
will have to pay for their destructive
agenda most likely from their pockets
when written house sues them
remember when president biden called
rittenhouse a white supremacist
does he stand by that statement
don't stand by your
past
well look i stand by what the jury has
concluded the jury system works and you
have to abide by it
and later joe biden's puppet masters
cleaned up his comment and forced him to
release a statement saying he was angry
angry about the verdict
this week the jury fought back against
the mob justice the left was pushing for
the media lost corrupt prosecutors lost
to fund the police lost and self-defense
won
this was a meaningful victory for
individual rights in the united states
of america hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else